well we just opened an exhibition called
Frank Lloyd Wright in the city density
versus dispersal which has an
interesting history because in long
conversations between Columbia MoMA and
the Frank Lloyd Wright Foundation about
the monumental historical transfer of
these archives we agree that there
should be some presentation to the
public a little bit after the first year
the idea that we would explore the idea
of the city through demonstrations of
Frank Lloyd Wright's work is what we
settled upon he'll look at the archive
through a research lens that
investigates not only the master works
but the master thinking of Frank Lloyd
Wright as a major figure in not only
American architecture but in
architectural thought and planning
across the world Wright had a
fascinating love-hate relationship with
cities in general and with New York City
in particular the centerpiece of the
exhibition and probably the largest
single object in the entire archive is
the model that he made of his conception
of broadacre City in the mid 1930s for
him broadacre city was a new kind of
city when we look at it we might even
think it's an anti City even as late as
the 1950s when he's doing the last
textual update of broadacre City he also
designs the Supreme skyscraper an idea
for a skyscraper one mile high for
Chicago which he says in one one note
among the papers in the archive this
tower could hold of the entire
population of broadacre city this man is
you know working with a good working
with an open contradiction in terms of
the audience that we bring students
classes from Columbia regularly are
going down to MoMA on gallery visits
with Barry or other members of the
curatorial team as well as coming in to
Avery archives to explore all the other
material that helps to flesh out the
themes that we're presenting in the
exhibition
current exhibition had its origins in a
class here at Columbia so the students
worked on those projects and discussed
them they went to see the exhibition
they almost felt as though it was their
exhibition at the end but they also
could see how the curatorial work works
how you have to make choices how you
have to tell a story a complicated story
with a small number of parts both
institution recognized that this would
involve a new kind of commitment between
our two cultural heritage institutions
and a set of transformational changes
would likely need to take place in each
of our operations independently and when
we work together
everybody knows frankly right drawings
few people understand how big the rest
of the archive actually is there's over
a thousand boxes that came with material
in it from the foundation in Scottsdale
there are boxes of Correspondence
roughly a hundred and twelve thousand
pieces of Correspondence over 40,000
photographs 600 manuscripts among many
other items there's also large numbers
of reels of film of Wright speaking or
being filmed scholarship on Frank Lloyd
Wright is probably along with liqueurs
EA the most voluminous on any architect
of the 20th century and up until the
trend of the transfer of these materials
to New York scholars of Frank Lloyd
Wright would need to seek out the
materials very poetically on the
properties that Frank Lloyd Wright it
creative but bringing them to New York
makes them infinitely more accessible to
many many more people one of the things
that to me is most striking for the
Frank Lloyd Wright archive or any
archive is the importance of the legacy
documentation there are Frank Lloyd
Wright buildings that were never built
there Frank Lloyd Wright buildings that
have been lost to us because of
destruction for one reason or another
the living evidence of that work is the
archival documentation so
having this repository is very important
for the hundreds of right buildings that
there are across the country and beyond
that's right also built in Japan for
instance homeowners meant an
extraordinary percentage of Wright's
buildings are actually houses we have
the records of their house so that's
incredibly valuable for Frank Lloyd
Wright owners all of these groups have
access to these extraordinary materials
at Avery together our resources in terms
of expertise and infrastructure can
support world-renowned collections
better than we could do individually
that's a key important thing and it is a
model making structure for not only the
MoMA Columbia collaboration but for
other institutions who may want to take
on the responsibility of major works
such as those a Frank Lloyd Wright